l'exode de la misère au bangladesh
maintenant depuis des semaines au sud de
l'asie
deux cent mille musulmans de la province
de l'arac ans en birmanie au sud du
bangladesh
juste en face de l'un deux cent mille
musulmans sont poussés hors de leur pays
par des luttes tribales religieuse
économique peut-être il y aurait des
odeurs de pétrole qui traînerait en 1 re
à quand ce qui rend cet exode encore
plus exceptionnel c'est que ces
populations famélique se réfugie chez
plus pauvres qu'eux au bangladesh on
touche dans ce reportage de roger pic
jacky de cargos ayant et françois aux
terres au plus profond de la misère de
masse et dans un pays bien misérable de
l'autre côté de cette rivière les
montagnes de birmanie l'un des pays les
plus secrets du monde dans ces barques
des birmans fui leur pays
d'après leurs témoignages rien ne va
plus en à rackham une grande province
côtière de la birmanie qui longe la
frontière et depuis le 23 avril dernier
la population musulmane de cette région
trouve un nazi une force et au
bangladesh
près de deux cent mille réfugiés birmans
ont déjà franchi cette rivière qui
sépare les deux pays
ils sont issus de la minorité ni des
rohingya ce qui représente près d'un
million et demi d'habitants
ce raz-de-marée humain a surpris par son
importance tous les observateurs en fait
la situation a commencé à se dégrader en
février dernier lorsque les birmans ont
lancé en art à cannes sous le prétexte
d'un contrôle de nationalité l'opération
dragoon rapidement l'héroïne gascon
compris qu'ils étaient la cible unique
de cette opération dès le mois de mars
ceux qui avaient échappé aux massacres
et aux fioles se pressaient à la
frontière du bangladesh où les
gardes-frontière bengali l'hérault puis
c'est comment l'un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde
pouvait-il accueillir des milliers
d'affamés supplémentaires le 23 avril
pourtant les bengalis n'ont rien pu
empêcher les soldats birmans ont ouvert
le feu sur l'héroïne des as qui végétait
le long du cours d'eau frontière et dans
une panique indescriptible
les birmans forcé en une journée 40000
ring as a passé au bangladesh depuis
l'hémorragie ne s'est plus arrêté
chaque nuit quatre ou cinq mille
nouveaux arrivants franchissent la
frontière en barque chargé d'enfants et
d'un misérable baluchon
entre le point de débarquement et le
premier bivouac où ils se rassemblent
les réfugiés ont parcouru ainsi 20 km à
pied
[Musique]
épuisés et affamés ils s'agglutinent aux
abords du premier campement rencontrés
dans l'espoir de recevoir quelques
nourritures ou de retrouver un parent un
ami
face à cette situation dramatique
le gouvernement du bangladesh a réagi
avec une efficacité évidente en six
semaines il a fait installer neuf camps
dont le plus proche de la birmanie
s'appelle lédat après quelques jours les
nouveaux arrivants ils seront
enregistrées puis envoyés vers d'autres
camps ici 62 bengali encadrent 28 mille
réfugiés à 12 km au nord dans le camp de
mila on dénombre dix sept mille enfants
de moins de 15 ans sur 21 mille
personnes les réfugiés dans leur immense
majorité sont des paysans complètement
il les traits un il a par exemple sur
21000 virement les bengalis en or sans
ces 128 seulement qui savent lire et
écrire
l'un d'eux un ancien étudiant de 22 ans
nous explique la situation en birmanie
l'opération dragoon et oui c'est une
opération officielle la police birmane
l'armée et l'immigration virmani
participent parfois c'est à dire les non
musulmans
les aides
déjà un torturé ou violentés oui j'en ai
vu beaucoup
d'abord ils ont violé toutes les femmes
les jeunes et les filles ou soeurs et
nos mères oui ma soeur aussi a été
violée par des soldats dans ce corps les
femmes violées sont très nombreuses vous
en rencontrerez beaucoup on peut
s'attendre à ce qu'il y en ait bien
d'autres c'est comme les nazis et hitler
vous connaissez les nazis hitler en
allemagne lire une gare sont torturés
comme lainesse il le faisait
l'opération dragon contre l'héroïne y at
elle commencé
ça a commencé le 6 février de cette
année d'abord un câble et dans le
district ensuite à boudy gones et un
manque d'eau spécialement l'hérault
dignard l'opération vise un million et
demi du sully religion oui c'est un
conflit religieux être un birman c'était
un vous dise tu sais la loi le
gouvernement utilise aujourd'hui cette
loi contre les nombrilistes sauvez-nous
du génocide
sauvez nous de l'exterminer arrêtez ce
génocide
[Musique]
dans les camps les réfugiés se réunit
cinq fois par jour pour la prière de ce
côté là au moins ils ne seront pas
inquiétés car le bangladesh est sans
doute l'état le plus religieux du monde
musulman
sarah palin
[Musique]
adou et gratuit
les femmes elles aussi consacrent
l'essentiel de leur temps à la prière
elle considère que si dieu les frappe
aujourd'hui c'est pour les punir des
fautes qu'elles ont précédemment comme
islam signifie l'abandon à dur
[Musique]
là il omet
là on
[Musique]
la terre
bah
un beau
[Musique]
conformément à l'usagé musulmans les
femmes restent cloîtrés sous les
paillotes où elle s'occupe de leurs
nombreux enfants et prépare les repas
les magali distribue quotidiennement à
chaque réfugiés adultes une livre de
farine mélangée de fluor et la moitié
seulement de cette quantité pour chaque
enfant avec cette ration de survie les
femmes confectionne des galettes que
l'on mangera en les trempant dans du thé
dans les camps quels que soient leur de
longues files d'attentes pour l'eau la
farine ou les formalités administratives
les agences internationales tels que
l'unicef et la croix rouge participe au
programme des premiers secours
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
organismes des nations unies vient
d'envoyer sur place un planificateur
monsieur pierre quoi tu comme vous le
savez le haut commissariat de faire
appel à la communauté internationale
principalement au gouvernement et un
appel a été lancé il ya 2 3 2 pour
obtenir environ 15 millions et demi de
dollars de ressources en espèces et en
nature pour venir en aide aux réfugiés
sur la base de deux cent mille personnes
puis d'ici à la fin d'année jusqu'à 78 à
peu près le commissariat
va pas ne peut pas organiser lui même
les secours
le gouvernement du bangladesh d'ailleurs
ne le souhaite pas c'est le gouvernement
qui organise les secours qui les
distribue avec la les conseils
la participation financière et l'aide
dans tous les domaines possibles
techniques etc
non seulement du haut commissariat pour
les réfugiés mais de toute l'équipe des
nations unies qui se trouve ici
[Musique]